it has been
2809 days since Donald Trump first
descended that golden escalator and
announced his bid for president and the
libs are still trying to lock him up
for something
anything
first they spied on his campaign
when that turned up nothing they
launched a special counsel investigation
to NAB him for allegedly colluding with
the Russians
when that didn't work they impeached him
for allegedly colluding with the
ukrainians
when that didn't work they impeached him
again for allegedly trying to overthrow
the government
when that didn't work
they impaneled a grand jury in Georgia
to investigate him for allegedly
pressuring the Georgia Secretary of
State Brad raffensberger
to challenge the results of the election
that is where we are now
and here is the foreman of that grand
jury Emily Coors explaining on National
Television what she hopes will come of
the investigation
after everything that you've seen what
would your reaction be if the D.A
decides against bringing any charges
after what you've seen
I will be sad if nothing happens
like that's that's about my only request
there is is for something to happen I
don't necessarily know what it is I'm
not the legal expert I'm not the judge
I'm not the lawyers but
I I will be frustrated if nothing
happens this was too much
twitch information too much of my time
too much of everyone's time too much of
their time
too much argument in in court about
getting people to appear before us there
was just too much for this to just be
oh okay we're good bye
and if it was just a perjury charge or
perjury charges would that be acceptable
to you that's fine
I would be happy as long as something
happens
ha ha something anything it's just taken
up so much time and effort not just for
her for all the libs who have spent now
seven years trying to get this guy each
time being foiled like Wiley Coyote
and after this grand jury Foreman's
extremely imprudent media tour which
could result in the whole shebang being
tossed out of court
it looks as though Roadrunner Donald has
managed to avoid yet another Acme Anvil
what is the Georgia grand jury even
about I had to remind myself of this
yesterday I said wait hold on they got
him now they are so close to getting
Trump again for something and then ah
foiled again at the last moment by this
this eccentric grand jury Foreman but
wait what are they getting him for now
and the grant the grand jury in Georgia
is about a phone call on January 2nd
2021 so just after the 2020 election
it's an hour-long conference call
that then president Donald Trump had
with Georgia Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger
and according to the reporting
it was Trump pressuring the Secretary of
State to cheat to change the results of
the election to hand it to Trump when
Biden really won it that's not what
happened that's not even if you look at
the details of what the Liberals say
about this phone call that's not what
they say happened
what the Liberals say about this phone
call
we have the transcript of it is they say
that Donald Trump said this
what I want is this I just want to find
uh 11 780 votes which is one more than
we have
the margin of defeat at that point was
eleven thousand seven hundred seventy
nine votes just one more than we have
now if the if the sentence ended there
you might say okay well maybe he's
pressuring the Georgia Secretary of
State to just make up a number and add
it to Trump's tally to steal the
election but that's not where the
sentence ends he says I just want to
find 11 780 votes which is one more than
we have because we won the state
he's saying we won the state
and the tally doesn't reflect that now
you might disagree you might say Trump
is delusional you might say there were
no Shenanigans in Georgia you might say
that there were no pipes bursting in the
middle of the night and that the poll
washers were watching everything and it
didn't take a very long time to count
those ballots and there weren't all
sorts of Shenanigans in Georgia that it
would appear that there were I certainly
think there were a lot of Shenanigans in
Georgia but you might say I totally
disagree with Trump that's not the point
the point is what was Trump saying on
the phone call Trump was saying we won
the state and I want the tally to
reflect that that's a very different
thing than saying we lost the state but
I want you to cheat and pretend that we
won it so the whole
nontroversy I think is laughable to
begin with and now we are seeing just
how laughable it is when this grand jury
Foreman is exposing it as a witch hunt
this woman Emily Coors
who who is the top juror now on this
grand jury
you she divulged
some information that she probably
shouldn't have not just about Trump but
about all sorts of indictments that may
or may not come down
is it would you say when it comes to
there are there are indictments
recommended of course is it more than 12
people is it more than 20 people
I think if you look at the page numbers
of the report there's about
six pages in the middle that got cut out
allow for spacing
it's not a short list
not a short list did you personally want
to hear from the formula I wanted to
hear from the former president but
honestly I kind of wanted to subpoena
the former president because I got to
swear everybody in and so I thought it'd
be really cool to get 60 seconds with
President Trump of me looking at him and
being like do you solemnly sweat and
beginning to swear him in I just I kind
of just thought that would be an awesome
moment uh-huh that's not as shirtless
she's talking about all sorts of things
that she should not be talking about
she's talking about witnesses that they
saw she's she's describing the witnesses
she said I found some of them credible
some of them I found funny saying all
sorts of things she shouldn't say and
then once at the end I just really wanna
be able to swear in Trump wouldn't that
be awesome
wouldn't that be so awesome
this might
destroy the entire prosecution case
against all of these people they might
have to throw the whole thing out and
then here's the kicker on top of it the
kicker on top I got to give credit to
jack besobic for this
Jack found a Pinterest account that
would appear to belong to this woman and
the Pinterest account includes different
Pinterest boards
about
witchcraft
so there's one about Wicca witchcraft
paganism all sorts of occult weird
spiritualist practices pages and pages
of this which means
because all eight all nature is but art
unknown to thee all chance Direction
which thou canst not see what that means
is
this is a literal Witch Hunt
and it's not a Witch Hunt in the sense
that people are hunting witches it's a
Witch Hunt in the sense that witches are
hunting Donald Trump it's an actual you
can't even
if you if a Hollywood scriptwriter turns
this into a producer the producer would
reject it for being too outrageous and
too on the nose
they would say oh no this grand jury
Foreman character this is too absurd
this would never really have they would
never say these things on National
Television she couldn't be an actual
witch no come on but that is
that is what's happening
it would appear to be a literal Witch
Hunt which it always has been the rest
of the show continues now we'll be
chatting with you in our Circle member
block go to dailywire.com Knowles use
code Knowles to check out for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]